le scénario aura duré deux minutes
samedi dernier deux individus
s'introduisent dans ce magasin et des
robes deux grandes bouteilles de vin le
propriétaire visionne les images et
décide de les poster sur facebook on
voulait juste à l'armée les autres
commerçants et dire stop on en a marre
c'est pas la première fois qu'on se fait
voler malheureusement ce ne sera pas la
dernière non plus nouvellement on en a
marre un poste qui fait mouche
quarante mille commentaires en quelques
jours pour cette chasse aux voleurs qui
se joue sur les réseaux sociaux
je vous soutiens j'espère que justice
sera faite
moi aussi je travaille dans le commerce
est marre de passer son temps à
surveiller ces malfrats
vous avez bien raison le droit c'est
d'abord pour les victimes même si le vol
est un délit ce que vous faites est
immoral on a des lois et des tribunaux
pour ça car la pratique est illégale
passible de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et
300 mille euros damende pour la police
c'est aussi un frein enquête
je fais même contre-productif puisque
déjà connaître la personne de m à chaque
fois le cachet de vérification du
travail effectué aux dérives et
d'erreurs d'interprétation hyper fun une
méthode qui n'a pas porté ses fruits
pour ce restaurateur dijonnais il y a
huit mois il avait publié sur internet
la vidéo d'un jeune homme détruisant sa
vitrine sans résultat au pire ça nous a
fait la publicité ça fait ça va marcher
commerce n'était pas le but mais bon
voilà
je regrette pas parce que je pense que
notre rôle en tant que citoyen c'est
aussi d'informer c'est si on avait pu
donner des éléments supplémentaires à
qui que ce soit et notamment la police 4
face au mieux son travail voilà on est
là pour ça aussi une pratique qui fait
en tout cas polémique
à ce jour aucun commerçant n'a été
condamné dans ce type d'affaires